"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
YOU HEAR ABOUT THAT BIG STUDY
CLAIMING BIG TECH REALLY DOESN’T
FAVOR LIBERALS?
IT WAS FUNDED BY A BIG TECH
LIBERAL.
BUT YOU WON’T FIND OUT THAT FACT
IN ANY OF THE MAINSTREAM REPORTS
BUT THE GUY BEHIND IT IS
BILLIONAIRE GREG MUBARAK, HE
ALSO DONATED MILLIONS TO FIGHT
FAKE NEWS AND A TOWN TO BUY THIS
CAMPAIGN AS WELL.
HE ALSO FOUNDED CRAIGSLIST, THE
ONLINE BULLETIN BOARD WHERE I
SELL MY DISCARDED SWIMWEAR.
LAST NIGHT, TUCKER REVEALED THE
STUDY WAS IN FACT NO STUDY AT
ALL.
>> CAN WE GET SOME NUMBERS ON
THAT, AND WHY YOU?
NO, ACTUALLY, WE CAN’T.
IN THE WORDS OF THE "STUDY,"
PINNING DOWN PRECISE PROPORTIONS
OF CENSORSHIP IS IMPOSSIBLE
BECAUSE TWITTER DOESN’T RELEASE
SUFFICIENT DATA.
ARE YOU FOLLOWING THE REASONING
HERE?
THEIR CONCLUSION, TWITTER IS NOT
BIASED AND WE CAN BE CERTAIN
IT’S NOT BIASED BECAUSE TWITTER
REFUSES TO RELEASE THE DATA ON
WHO IT BANDS.
>> Greg: IN OTHER WORDS, A
FAKE STUDY FOR A GUY WHO CLAIMS
HE DOESN’T LIKE FAKE NEWS.
IT WAS DESIGNED FOR THE MEDIA SO
THEY WOULDN’T HAVE TO DO THEIR
JOBS AND INVESTIGATE THE ACTUAL
CLAIMS, BUT THE "RESEARCH" IS
ABOUT AS A RESEARCHY AS TURNING
ON THE LIGHTS TO YOUR LIVING
ROOM TO ASSESS THE EXISTENCE OF
WHALES.
YEP, NO WHALES THERE.
REALLY, HAVING A BIG TECH LIB
FUND A STUDY ON WHETHER BIG TECH
IS BIASED, THAT’S LIKE ME
FINDING A STUDY ON HOW GREAT I
AM, OR A STUDY SAYING JESSE HAS
THE BEST HAIR IN CABLE NEWS AND
IT’S FUNDED BY THE JESSE WATTERS
INSTITUTE FOR FOLLICULAR
STUDIES.
OR HOW ABOUT WHEN INCLUDING THAT
JASPER IS INDEED AMERICA’S DOG
AND THAT IS FUNDED BY
DANA PERINO UNIVERSITY OF DOG
SELFIES.
AND DID YOU KNOW THAT
JUAN WILLIAMS IS RIGHT ON
EVERYTHING?
THAT RESEARCH WAS FUNDED BY
JUAN WILLIAMS.
SO BEFORE YOU SEE A STUDY THAT
SAYS THERE IS NO MASSIVE CRIME
WAVE, I WOULD CHECK FIRST TO SEE
IF IT WAS FUNDED BY CRIMINALS,
OR WORSE, CNN.
THE FACT IS THE GREAT THING
ABOUT BEING A RICH LAB, YOU CAN
BUILD A CASE FOR ANYTHING AND
THE MEDIA WILL BACK YOU UP
100%.
IT’S HOW THEY LIED TO YOU AND
KEEP YOU IN THE DARK BEER BUT OF
COURSE THAT IS ALL B.S.
ACCORDING TO A NEW STORY BY THE
PEOPLE WHO LIE TO YOU AND KEEP
YOU IN THE DARK.
YOU KNOW, I DIDN’T KNOW YOU ARE
ON THE SHOW TODAY SO I DIDN’T
COME UP WITH THE STUDY FOR YOU,
SO IF YOU WERE COMMISSIONING A
STUDY ON YOURSELF, WHAT WITH THE
IDEAL CONCLUSION BE?
>> Dagen: THAT I THINK THE
PROPER WAY OF DROPPING YOUR Gs
IS THE PROPER WAY BURMA SHOULD
PRONOUNCE YOUR WORDS
I’M SPEAKING THE KINGS AND THE
QUEEN’S ENGLISH OVER HERE, I
DON’T KNOW WHAT Y’ALL ARE
SPEAKING.
>> Greg: ARE YOU SURPRISED BY
THIS FINDING?
>> Dagen: NOT AT ALL BECAUSE
YOU ARE DESCRIBING THE LEFT
WING NUT ARMADA.
YOU’VE GOT THE TECH INDUSTRY AND
THE TECH MONOPOLY IS
ALL-POWERFUL AND UNCHECKED,
ALONG WITH THE MEDIA, ALONG WITH
ACADEMIA IN THE GOVERNMENT, THEY
DON’T HAVE OPINIONS, MIND YOU,
THEY ARE RIGHT, THEY ARE
CORRECT, THEY ARE JUST, AND THEY
ARE MORAL.
THERE IS ONLY ONE LEGITIMATE
POINT OF VIEW AND IT IS THEIRS,
AND IF YOU DON’T FALL IN LINE
WITH THEM, IF YOU DON’T AGREE
WITH THEM, YOU’RE WRONG AND NOW
THEY ARE SO EMBOLDENED AND
ALIGNED WITH ONE ANOTHER, IT
WILL ALSO DESTROY YOU.
YOU SEE THAT WITH TECHNOLOGY,
JUST WITH THE SHUTTING DOWN OF
PARLER.
BUT WE’VE BEEN HERE BEFORE AND
ULTIMATELY, PEOPLE TURNED
AGAINST THE OUTRAGE AND CANCEL
SHIP OF THE RED SCARE, THE HOUSE
UN-AMERICAN COMMITTEE, AND
McCARTHYISM.
BUT THE SCARY THING IS EVEN OF
RIGHTEOUSNESS WHEN THE, THERE’S
A LOT OF CARNAGE BEFORE THAT
HAPPENS WITH LIVES AND
LIVELIHOODS DESTROYED.
WORST-CASE SCENARIO IS THAT THE
DAMS COME OF THIS KIND
COLLECTIVE JOINING IN
, THEY WENT OUT AND DEMOCRATS
ARE IN POWER AND ANYONE WHO HAS
A DIFFERENT OPINION OR A DIFFERE
YOU ARE DESTROYED AND SO IS OUR
REPUBLIC.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, STUDIES
LIKE THIS, OR WHEN THE MEDIA
COVERS STUDIES LIKE THIS, ISN’T
IT THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO SAY
WHO PAID FOR IT?
WHEN I WORKED IN HEALTH
JOURNALISM THERE WAS ALWAYS A
LITTLE NOTE AT THE END OF THE
STORY, THIS STUDY ON ORANGE
JUICE REDUCING CHOLESTEROL WAS
FUNDED BY THE ORANGE JUICE
BOARD.
IT WAS ALWAYS KIND OF, THEY HAD
TO DO IT.
>> Juan: I DON’T THINK IT WAS
HIDDEN, GREG.
BUT I MUST SAY I’M STRUCK BY
WHAT YOU SAID IN THE TERMS THAT
USUALLY YOU AND I DISAGREE, AND
I THINK THIS MAY BE AN OCCASION
WHERE WE MEET AT THE MOUNTAINTOP
BUT WE COME OFF DIFFERENT SIDES
OF THE MOUNTAIN.
BUT BECAUSE FROM MY SIDE OF THE
MOUNTAIN, I THINK BIG TECH, WITH
ITS ABILITY TO TELL US HOW TO
THINK, WHAT TO BUY, I THINK THAT
IS TOO BIG AND THEY NEED TO BE
REGULATED AND IN SOME CASES MAY
BE EVEN BROKEN UP, BUT THEY
CERTAINLY NEED SOME KIND OF
INTERFACE WITH THE PUBLICS OF
THE PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS WHAT’S
GOING ON AND WHY THEY DO WHAT
THEY DO AND WHEN THEY DO IT.
THEY ARE TOO POWERFUL.
BUT FROM MY SIDE OF THE
MOUNTAIN, I JUST WANTED TO SAY,
II DON’T WANT CONSERVATIVE
THOUGHT LIMITED.
I DON’T THINK IT IS LIMITED.
WHEN I LOOK AT THESE PLATFORMS,
I SEE BEN SHAPIRO, I SEE
DAN BONGINO, THEY’VE GOT THE
LEADING SITES OUT THERE, MANY OF
THEM ARE CONSERVATIVE SITES THAT
ARE THE TOP SITES ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
SO I DON’T SEE THAT THERE IS ANY
BIAS AGAINST THE CONSERVATIVES.
BUT WHEN I THINK WE START
TALKING ABOUT KILLING
POLITICIANS, WHEN YOU START
PLOTTING VIOLENT, SEDITIOUS ACTS
AGAINST THE CAPITAL OF THE
UNITED STATES, WHEN YOU EMBRACE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, WHEN THAT
KIND OF TRASH IS SPREAD ON THESE
SITES, I DON’T THINK PEOPLE HAVE
A LEGITIMATE RIGHT TO SAY --
THIS IS DAMAGING TO US AS A
COUNTRY, AS A SOCIETY, TO OUR
ABILITY TO HAVE HONEST DISCOURSE
AND THAT IS WHAT’S GOING ON.
I THINK THAT IS WHERE YOU SEE
TODAY IN THE CONGRESS, YOU HAVE
REPUBLICANS LIKE
MITCH McCONNELL, SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER SAYING THAT KIND
OF THINKING IS CANCEROUS AND
DANGEROUS NOT ONLY TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY BUT TO US AS AN
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THAT’S
WHAT’S GOING ON HERE.
I DON’T CARE WHO PAID FOR THE
STUDY, I JUST THINK WE NEED TO
COME TOGETHER AND SAY, YOU KNOW,
THIS KIND OF INTERNET SENSATION
IS DISTORTING OUR PUBLIC
DISCOURSE IS DAMAGING.
>> Greg: BUT YOU KNOW, JESSE,
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER TO THIS, IT
DEPENDS ON WHO YOU ARE BECAUSE
THIS DOESN’T APPLY TO
CELEBRITIES ON TWITTER WHO SAY
BURN IT ALL DOWN OR PEOPLE
MAKING THREATS TO TRUMP OR TO
TRUMP SUPPORTERS OR ANY KIND OF
OMINOUS WARNINGS TO ANYBODY THAT
IS NOT A LEFTIST, THAT STUFF USE
TO FLY RIGHT BY.
YOU COULD TWEET SUPPORT --
THAT’S OKAY.
>> Jesse: PERMISSION TO MAKE A
SPORTS ANALOGY?
>> Greg: PERMISSION GRANTED.
>> Jesse: OKAY, SO YOU’RE
WATCHING A FOOTBALL GAME AND ON
EVERY SINGLE PLAY THE REFEREES
FLAG A PENALTY ON TEAM.
THEY NEVER FLAG PENALTY AND THE
OTHER TEAM AND YOU GET BLOWN
OUT.
THEN HE ANNOUNCES COME ON THE
AIR AND SAY, WASN’T THAT A VERY
WELL CALLED GAME?
THEN YOU FIND OUT THE ANNOUNCERS
ARE ON THE PAYROLL OF THE OTHER
TEAM.
THAT IS HOW RIGGED THIS IS.
I CAN’T NAME ONE LIBERAL WHO HAS
BEEN FLAGGED OR CENSORED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
I MEAN, DAN BONGINO AND
BEN SHAPIRO, THEY HAVE BEEN
FLAGGED AND CENSORED.
YOU’RE TELLING ME THE PART OF
THE LEFT IS A LIAR PUSH FAKE
NEWS?
AT THE COVINGTONS, THE
COLLUSIONS, THE MAILBOX HOAXES,
THE HANDS UP DON’T SHOOT STOMACH
SHOOTERS, THE PEOPLE WHO SAID
THE ARCTIC ICE CAPS WERE GOING
TO MELT 20 YEARS AGO.
YOU’RE GOING TO GIVE ONE
POLITICAL PARTY A MONOPOLY ON
THE TRUTH?
IN THAT CASE, 150 YEARS AGO, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY’S TRUTH
COMMISSION WOULD HAVE SAID
SLAVERY IS GREAT, AND THEY WOULD
HAVE CALLED THE ABOLITIONISTS
PEOPLE PUSHING DISINFORMATION.
SEE WHAT I DID THERE?
WHAT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT IS THE
LEGACY MEDIA LOSING THEIR SHARE
IN THE MARKETPLACE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THEY LIVE, AND
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT,
SOCIAL MEDIA, FOX NEWS AND
PODCASTS ARE STARTING TO GAIN
TRACTION.
INSTEAD OF COMPETING WITH THEM
THEY ARE CONSPIRING WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
SILICON VALLEY TO SLAP A DANGER
LABEL ON CONSERVATIVE
INFLUENCERS AND PROPPING UP
CZARS AND COMMISSIONS TO SHUT
THEM DOWN BECAUSE THEY CAN’T
COMPETE WITH THEM.
>> Greg: I THINK I LEARNED
IT’S GOOD WE DIDN’T HAVE THE
INTERNET BACK DURING THE
CIVIL WAR, DANA.
FINAL THOUGHTS TO YOU.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Dana: FIRST OF ALL, I NEVER
HAD A CANDLE.
I DON’T THINK I EVEN HAD A
BARBIE BECAUSE MY PARENTS
WOULDN’T BUY ME ONE AND THEY
DIDN’T BELIEVE IN THE WHOLE
BARBIE THEME, SO I DIDN’T GET
MONO FROM KISSING A KEN DOLL.
>> Greg: THAT’S ALL YOU’VE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT IN THIS
BLOCK CUSTOMER KEEP IN THINKING
ABOUT THAT INTRO THE ENTIRE
BLOCK?
>> Dana: IT HIT ME BY SURPRISE
BUT I LOVED IT.
THIS IS WHAT I WANTED TO SAY, IN
ADDITION TO THE CENSORSHIP
ISSUE, THERE’S A WHOLE ISSUE OF
BEING COMPLIANT WITH THE TERMS
OF SERVICE.
NOW, WE COULD ALL SAY, IF THE
TERMS OF SERVICE, YOU SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT, BUT THAT
ISN’T APPLIED EVENLY FROM
LIBERALS TO CONSERVATIVES.
I WILL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
THINK OF JIMMY KIMMEL.
THEIR SHOW PUT UP A FAKE VIDEO
OF VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
PUTTING EMPTY BOXES OF PPE OUT.
THAT’S CLEARLY AGAINST TERMS OF
SERVICE, YOU CAN’T MANIPULATE
VIDEO.
IT TOOK A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
OUTRAGE TO GET TWITTER TO FLAG
IT, TAKE IT DOWN.
CONTRAST THAT WITH, TAKE YOUR
PICK.
THERE WAS ONE TIME WHEN
DONALD TRUMP JR. PUT UP A VIDEO
OF BIDEN THAT WAS OUT OF CONTEXT
AND MADE IT LOOK LIKE HE WAS
STUMBLING OVER HIS WORDS BUT
ACTUALLY, IT WASN’T THAT, IT
WASN’T MANIPULATED, BUT IT
DIDN’T HAVE FULL CONTEXT.
IT WAS IMMEDIATELY FLAGGED.
IF THINGS WERE APPLIED EVENLY I
THINK PEOPLE WOULD HAVE A LITTLE
BIT MORE CONFIDENCE.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU’RE